400 trillion to one those are the odds
of becoming a human being you are more
likely to win the lotto 10 times in your
life than actually having one so can we
please make this video the moment when
you decide to stop dwelling stop crying
don't tell me how you blew your knee out
in high school it is time to take
control and what are you gonna see
sitting at 80 90 years old in a
retirement home regretting all the
things you didn't do take Life by the
throat and go out and execute everything
that happened has happened no more
dwelling no more complaining so right
now wrap your head around this
ridiculous gift that you were given it's
called life go step out and do your
thing the one thing you've always wanted
to do or the 10 50 100 things you've
always tried to do because the only
thing that's keeping you back is the
other people that are judging you and
who gives a [__] about them